there have been rumors of an alliance at
the edge of the Galaxy there's a
tremendous amount of detail that's
required in bringing Foundation to life
this season is a lot bigger than the
first season in scale and scope
everything's so detailed everything's
put together so well it's insane the
Wardrobe the set designs they're all
completely brilliant we show this
Factory progression of Technology
roughly speaking it takes us 2 years to
make a season figure 6 months for
pre-production 7 to 8 months of filming
and then close to a year post-production
because we have so many visual effects
our real goal on the show is to give
people that scope that they don't expect
on
television hang
[Music]
on and action when I started Foundation
I decided that I want to film as much of
it on location as possible I want the
crew and the actors to feel the heat to
feel the wind because I felt that it
would just make everything feel more
real smart boy season 2 is very much a
story of asymmetrical Warfare the
foundation compared to Empire is a speck
but slowly but surely the foundation is
gaining
influence they've grown and they've
taken over the outskirts of the Galaxy
the sets and the locations that we've
been on for both seasons have been
picked out so incredibly it helps us
create the world and it makes it so much
easier to be in the moment season 2 goes
all over the place there are a lot of
new worlds and they're all very
different we able to find all these new
planets and give them a unique
look we're going to return to tranor in
Ireland we had the main Palace sets the
original mirror of Souls and we built a
new clone tank set we're also back in a
different syx a syx that's completely
covered in
water the world of ignis we had the
jungle in the Czech Republic but there
are oceans in ignis so those scenes were
shot in the canaries I spent 3 days on
sandunes and it was miles away from
everywhere else but we have so much fun
on set I love every second of it we're
in the Summer Palace we wanted the
elements in this set it feel like you
were in this Encore watt type of jungle
Palace whoever's in charge please could
we end this charade I thought you might
be the one to
notice Terminus where the church of
Seldon is was actually shot in the old
scota factory in the Czech Republic
terminous city is in Fort fentura and
it's just so real it's in the middle of
an empty space and they've built a
village it's not difficult to imagine
you're on a Barren Planet a lot of the
Loc that we've chosen the population in
North America have not seen or don't
know about so that lets us spend more
time in those locations as our backdrops
for all of the storytelling as if it's
an alien world and we're always trying
to push the look of the
show wow look at
you the fashion in season 2 it's just
fantastic our costume designer jamee
Petri she and her team had to come up
with thousands upon thousands of
costumes we're flying through nine
planets there's no through thread so we
have to come up with a whole new concept
for each planet and a new backstory for
where the costumes have come from one of
the things that we really wanted to do
with season 2 with our costumes was just
explode the color pallet we've got these
wonderfully Lush Reds that are embodied
by the church of the galactic Spirit
we've got these kind of rainbow colors
that are embodied by Cloud Dominion
compared to season one it's been really
good to get outside more it's a little
bit brighter we go to more planets so
there's a lot more
variety welcome to trenter this season's
day is completely different than last
season's day has turned in his blue
armor he's gotten a little bit more
flamboyant he's wearing chain mail this
season
Seldon allow me to present the doen of
the trade leagues sarth I first sole
descendant of Dominion
Cloud Dominion they come from a place
where they produce the best pigments in
the Galaxy all the Imperial Blues in
pure form with two slices of Agate and
worked them into a print and we had
these big billowing robes the look of
Queen sarth and enjoy Naro and all of
the cloud Dominion is different to
anything I've ever seen Cloud Dominion
is the exact opposite of what tranor is
which is blues Classics and everything
is so strict and then you have these
women come into this universe and
everything is billowy and
feminine what brings you to our world
for season 2 the location that really
has embedded itself in costumes would be
ignis there's an awful lot of the
environment around them that I felt
would really be part of their clothing
and then we worked with all of the
colors of the plant life and the
vegetation we need your help I like my
plan wherein we keep to
ourselves Foundation is the most complex
show in terms of post- production of any
project I've ever been involved in on
average we have about 4,000 visual
effect shots per
season the goal is to get everything
photo real to get the spaceships to move
like we think spaceships would really
move to get our creatures to have the
same kind of fidelity that any kind of
animal would in our
world I have stories in me many stories
would you like to hear one de El's
dungeon and how she's been split into
pieces was based on the idea that she
can heal herself and make herself whole
at any point so the prison had to
reflect that she could be kept separated
by glass panes and her circuitry was
then sandwiched between them and then on
the outer slices was her human form
front and back and painted her circuitry
onto these glass panes with LED lighting
to make it feel physical and then my
team will go back in and will augment
and give it that little bit of extra
love to make it feel
real we probably spend a couple of weeks
coloring each
episode going through it shot by shot
trying to make everything as Artful as
possible it's a highly technical process
you can change the mood of the scene by
making it darker and blue sometimes
they're shooting over 3 days which one
day it's raining and the next day it's
not so integrating all of those shots
back together with visual effect shots
requires a level of intricacy and detail
[Music]
and then you've got sound you've got a
sound team called sound dogs who are
incredible our job is to help supplement
and exaggerate a lot of the visuals that
we're seeing I think just a little at
the head and then then you're good this
year there's beaches and now you're
dealing with waves and sounds that are
clobbering the dialogue a bit so you're
trying to clean all that up for Tyler's
part and his crew they're creating
sounds of ships that don't really exist
creatures that don't exist this you're
building a sound World from scratch
there's always a sense of Discovery in
this process I believe that post
production are one of the things that
really makes Foundation feel different
and more cinematic than your average
show I think it's kind of cool yeah nice
job guys only Empire commands the Stars
crush them now show
forward I can't wrap my head around the
craftsmanship on this show the attention
to detail is just extraordinary that you
could only really get on a production
like
this the stakes are much higher in
season 2 the Galaxy is countless number
of planets 10,000 inhabited worlds so we
see more of them this season I didn't
think that it could get any more vast
and somehow some way the team has made
it even bigger in season 2 The Rocket
takes off and we've been having an
absolute
blast is such an incredible spectac and
I've never seen anything like
it Empire and Reckoning I am so grateful
and lucky that I get to be a part of
this and I think we really succeeded in
season 2 and it was a real treat
bringing it to
life
here
w